はい それで仏教的なところに入ってみると
この行進を止めてほしいんですね
観察というGPSで位置を確認してほしいんです
GPSご存知でしょうね
自分がどこにいるのかという確認している
車についているやつですね
で 観察するということは
自分のGPSなんて人生の
それで自分がこの行進する道でどんな辺に位置にいるのかということは発見することが必要です
はい では旅の始まりということで
必要なものがあると感じたから
生きる旅が始めたんですね
これ GPSの確認ですね
我々は生きる旅はなんで始めたのかというと
なんかいろんなものが必要になっちゃったんですね
それで生きることをスタートするんです
しかし 必要なものとは具体的にという不可欠な
確認ポイントを無視したのです
ちょっとなんかちょっと簡単でなくなっちゃったみたいですね
で 命が生きるということは
我々は必要なものを探すことなんです
それは生きることです
だから 生きる旅の始まりは必要なものが生じたことなんです
まあ例わかりやすい例にしますけど
後で来るかもしれませんだけど
赤ちゃんが生まれる 生まれた瞬間で赤ちゃんは産気づいなっちゃうんですね
そうすると酸素が必要ということになっちゃうんです
それで赤ちゃんがオギャーと言って
もう命が始まるんです
それから死ぬまでやってます
いろんな仕事 だから必要ですよ
必要ということなんですね
ネセシティー あのネセシティーっていうのは
この想像力の親という英語のことわざがあるんですけどね
まああまり合ってないと言いますけどね
これがもう悪魔的な生き方の親なんですけど
しかし我々は必要って何が必要という
これに答え出さないんですね
だから GPS で自分がいる場所を確認していないんです
いる場所っていうのは
我々生きているものだから
いる場所はどこでもいいんだけど
自分に必要なものは具体的に何なのかと
それを確認しないと生きていられないんです
やみくもに探しただけで
ものを貯める生き方になって
溜まったものの中に潰れかけているんです
そこでとにかく必要ですが
何が必要かよくわからないんだから
とりあえずいろいろもう取りまくおると
いう生き方なんです 生きる
生き 生きて生きる必要があるんだ
生きるために もういろんなものが必要だ
いろんなものって何？わからない
だったらもうとりあえずもう必死になって
何でもいいんだからもう獲得しなさいと
そういうことで 何でも取って取って取って潰されているんですね
もう動かなくなってるんです
人間が なぜ必要と生きることに何かが欠けているので
その何かが必要になるんです
で もう皆様 今 今日明日もうね
お祝いする宗教ではね
この命というのは神様が作ったというんだからね
あれもうもの最高 最低の下手な神様で命を作ったんですけど
いろんなものを欠けているんですね
生きていられないんですね
だから命を 生を取ったところで
まず見えるのは あらゆるものは欠けているんですね
もう成り立たない命は
だからもう何としてでも必死でこの欠けているものを入れないと
壊れるんです この欠けてるのは何？それがなくては決して生きていられないのでしょうかと
それを調べなくちゃいけないんですね
我々に欠けているものは何でしょうかと
また なくても間に合えるものはあるんですかと
また 生きることに問題はないが
少々アクセント 塩コショウ少々かけたのですかと
また 何も欠けてはないが
他人と差をつけたかったのでしょうかと
これ微妙にわからなくなってしまったんです
私は あの 普通 経典的で言えば
必要なものは分析してほしいんです 1
不可欠なもの  2 不可欠と言い難いんですけど
あった方が便利なもの
いわゆる間に合える もう何とかで間に合うことができれば
まあそれは 2番目 ちょっともうちょっとアクセントをつけるために
人生に必要なもの じゃあわかりやすい例で言いましょうか
服が必要ですけど まあ気に入ってる色にする
別に色はどうでもいいんですよ
服 服だったら だから色はデザインのアクセントなんですね
必ず必要というわけじゃないんです
服は必ず必要なんですね
だから服が必ず不可欠ですが
色とデザインはちょっとした塩こしょう
それがなくたっても大丈夫という
その理解が必要なんです
そこで 4番目 ただ差をつけるために頑張るんですよ
別荘を作ったりすると
そうすると他の人々に別荘がないんだからね
結構立場が差をつけられます
まあそういう感じで まああるいはもう高価なアクセサリーを買ったりするとかね
で カバンはやっぱりブランドのものにするとか
それでも差をつける目的なんですね
だから その 4つのカテゴリーに必要というネセシティーというものを分けない限り
人生は不幸です 悪魔に包囲されたまんまになるんです
で 私は一つも否定しませんよ
言いたいのは 不可欠なものはもうちゃんと取りなさい
でなきゃ死にます 次に役に立つもの
次にそれに挑戦する それできたら
次に 3番目のアクセント
塩こしょうもつけてみると
それも何の問題もなければ
もう余分に差をつけるために頑張ればいいんです
この順番あべこべになって
初めからもう差をつけようとしてるんです
時々は本当に食べ物を買うお金もない
女性の方々はもう文化縛りで高価な服やアクセサリー買ったりするんです
飢えていますけど 実際は
しかし 外へ出る時はもう立派なお嬢様で
もう何の問題もないように見えるんですね
しかし 階段を上がる能力
体力はないんです で 年を取ったら
私は階段上がらなくちゃいけないし
みんなエレベーター占領するんだから
若い子たちは 以上 記した 4つの確認ポイントはなぜ無視されたのでしょうかと
基本的になくてはならない
生きていられない 必要不可欠なものがあったのです
我々にあったんですよ
必要不可欠なもの 一つは酸素
水 ないとすぐ死んじゃいます
それから栄養 体っていうのは本当に立派な神様
すごくちょっとひどいことで壊れるんです
命は危うくなり 苦しみに陥っていたのです
冷静に観察できる状態ではなかったのです
これ ちょっとポイント変わります
我々は何でこの GPS 機能を使わなかったんですかね
余裕がなかったんです
赤ちゃんで考えたら 赤ちゃんもそんな余裕がないんですよ
もう息できなくて ものすごい苦しいんです
生まれた瞬間で だから必死で呼吸するしかないんです
それからも我々は死にかけている
いつでも死にかけているんです
そうするとものすごい苦しいんですね
だからこんな GPS なんか見ていられる場合じゃないんです
やみくもにもう頑張らなくちゃいけないという
この罠があるんですね
それでもがくことになるんですね
生を受けると同時に酸欠状態になる
これは例ですよ 死の恐怖感
苦しみが生じる 何でもいいから何かをくれと切望するため
羽目になる 我々はもうもう調べる余裕がないので
何でもいいんだから何かくれという
かなりもう大変な状態に生きているんです
だから何でもいいんだから何かくれと言ったって
何をあげればいいんですかね
本人が何かくれと言わないと
水をくれとか ご飯くれとかね
だから我々大人が他の人になんでもいいんだからなんとかくれと
死にそうになってるんだよと言ったって
何をあげればいいんですかね
じゃあ電車の切符でもあげたら
だからこのなんでもいいんだから何かくれっていう話では生きていられないんですね
なのに我々はそういう生き方をしているんです
要するに 生きることが苦だからこそ観察する余裕がなく
もがく羽目になったんです
我々はハメられているんです
もがく羽目になってるんです
理由は生きることは苦なんです
だけど この真理をお釈迦様がもうだから人類のために発見したんだというんです
人間に発見できないんですよ
こんな余裕がないんです
それで度を越した愚かさという
酸素 栄養などの物質を取り入れないと
瞬時に肉体が壊れる 心に対象がないと心も苦しみを感じる
この 2つはあるんです
体には栄養やら酸素やら入れないと瞬時に壊れて死んでしまいますね
心にもすーっと刺激が欲しいんです
でないとかなり壊れてしまいます
命を維持するためことは
終わりのない気が遠くなる作業です
ただ生きることだけにしても
気が遠くなる話ですよ
しかし その実態を見事に無視して
生きることは尊い幸福だと決めつける
度を越した愚かさです
何の研究もしていない
悪いに悪いに 生きることは尊い
命は尊い よく言うんです
これが私は度を越した愚かさと名付けているんです
それで仏教が宿題を与えています
なぜこの世で生きること
命を守ることだけ それほど難しいんですかね
家を守ることは簡単ですよ
ホコリがたまらないように
床はピカピカになる いつでも 5
6年 10年使っても 床はピカピカとかね
柱とかはすごい綺麗にピカピカと
そういう風に守ること
とんでも簡単ですけど
命はどうですかね なんで命だけそんなに守り難いんですかね
他のものは別にそんなに手を加えなくても
例えば鶏を健康的で生かしてあげるってこと
大変ですよ 一旦鶏が死んじゃってモノになったらね
冷凍庫に放り投げればね
1年でも2年でも持ちます
鶏に命があると これで守るのは大変なんです
なんででしょうかね これは
なぜ紙で折った鶴でも保管すれば 100年も持つのに
この命だけは脆いのですかと考えてほしいんです
それ宿題ですね 仏教の
なぜ壊れてもいいのに
命が壊れるのは苦しいんですかね
そんなに脆いんだったら壊れちゃえばいいでしょうに
そう放っておけないんですね
結局は 命っていうのはもうもう紙 1枚よりも脆いんだったら
もういいや 壊れたってもと
放っておけないでしょ
あれなんですかね 存在で
極限に脆い命を維持することは極限に苦ではないでしょうかと
幸福だと言うんですかと
命は極限に苦しいんですよ
あの命を 極限に脆い命は
例えば私のポケットにボールペンがあるとしましょう
もう 100円 4本買えるボールペン
そのボールペン1本と私の命と比較すると
どちらの方が強いんですかね
ボールペンの方が強いでしょうね
それ 100円で 4本も買えますからね 100
円ショップで そんなに大した価値もないものでも強いんです
それに比較すると この命は
だから命が極限に脆い
極限に脆いものが守ってるんだからね
これって大変なご苦労さんじゃないんですかね
極限にご苦労さんですよ
本当に文字通り だって
いくら守ったっても死にますからね
そういう宿題を仏教がね
人々を勘察してほしいと思うんですよ
数学の試験に音楽の塾に通うというね
我々の生き方を例えたんです
試験を受けたいんだけど
数学の試験ですけど 塾に行くんです
行く塾は音楽を教える塾なんです
タイトルが人間の生き方を表現するもの
命は苦であるという発見に余裕がないとしても
必修という項目を調べるべきでしたんです
生きることは苦であるということは
まあ忘れたってのはまあちょっといいんです
それより生きるために必要なもの
それなんで調べなかったんですか
1 不可欠なもの  2 あれば助かるもの
3 不可欠ではないが あれば便利
楽  4 余分に飾りになるもの
5 いらないものという分析がないんです
その分析がしてほしいんです
かなりスピードを上げないと
道から外れると 必要なものの分類をしてからカタログを作る必要があるんですね
あの 5つに分類して それからカタログを作る
それから目的があって
たどるところがはっきりして
生きることに挑戦できたはずです
目的があったらね 頑張れるのに
しっかり それで目的に達したら楽しいのに
ではなく 必要はごちゃ混ぜ
必要なリストは何でも記入できるように完全開放
あれ カタログ作ってないんです
まだ開放 何でもいいんだから書いてください
締め切りないんです 必要なリストには
それで結果として欲も要求も無限になるんです
あの具体的に無限というわけじゃないんです
我々の気持ち的には 要求も欲も無限なんです
これが道から外れたことになるんです
生きる道から外れたんです
だからお釈迦様は俗世の人々は生きていないんだと何のことなく言うんです
はい 無限の要求から無限の苦が生まれるんです
もともと苦をなくすために必要なものを要求するようになるはずでしたが
要求のカタログがないので
要求を満たすことは終わりのない苦しみを増幅するばかりの作業になっているんです
生きるということはそういう作業です
カタログがないんだからね
いくらでも要求リスト増えますからね
だったらいくらでも苦労しなくちゃいけないことになるんです
まあ大のね 苦を忘れて
まあ苦は大だから大きいんだからね
瞬間の快楽 瞬間の楽しみを目指すことになっているんです
すごいおかしいことっていうのは
あの苦の方が大なのに
わずかな楽もありますよ
あ それ見てすごいすごいと言うんです
いわゆるお金で言えば皆さんはよくわかりますからね
100万円を持っていって全部払って
あるいは忘れて落として
100円のおにぎりを買ってくる
よかった よかった  100円のおにぎりあったとか
それでお金はあれ どこか落ちた
忘れちゃったと でも 100 が 100万円なくなったって
まあこれあるでしょうにと
これ食べられる 食べられますよ
でもこんな生き方 理性的ですか？と
だからすごい苦しみを経た結果
わずかな楽しみが生まれる
楽を探して苦を得る とは人生です
人生はもう一行にまとめる
生きるとは楽を探して苦を得ることです
えーと やっと半分ぐらいになりましたので
ちょっとお休憩いたします
はい